welcome back to true news sub-story
rinds in a shirt where'd you get that I
don't know
Christmas present well no it's not been
a happy Christmas for everyone that the
homeless no it's not been a happy
Christmas for everyone in the world
though the homeless know again you've
got a really got to let me finish the
line
[Music]
just a recap for everyone obviously
there's been issues in the Olatunji
household mm-hmm it all started after
Randolph made a diss track on dead G and
then dead G sort of used the bunch
statements of JG embarrass Randolph JG
was a bit disappointed in his brother
father he blocked him temporarily on
social media home now daddy didn't take
kindly to that and sort of rose to fight
back as he puts it and in fighting back
it's been quite a lot yeah it not really
just blocked him back he's sort of gone
overboard a lot you know when someone
blocked on social media but they are a
massive celebrity with public accounts
you log on and see what they do it yeah
I mean it really is it's difficult yeah
yeah I mean it's not like on Sylvia's
block Deji rung JJ and asked if he could
put the district open JJ apparently said
okay and do it I think JJ was obviously
hoping that his brother wouldn't release
a diss track on his own brother then he
goes on the log and Paul podcast hey Jay
it said specifically do not do that dead
G whatever you do don't go on the log
and Paul podcast yeah and did you went
I'm going under a bridge mate see ya
then obviously JJ's probably pretty
pissed off at this point Christmas dear
comes yeah he goes back JJ says I want
to delete everything yeah I'll pay you
the money that you've lost on the videos
whatever
I'll get runned off to delete his videos
about you it'll all be squash what does
daddy say I know what AG says sorry mate
no room at the end no actually he locked
himself in his right locked himself in
his room Iran how you doin
yeah ironically
I get this plate is all over Twitter see
and you know it's all gone [__] the
right [__] yeah daddy then does another
video on Gigi on Christmas Day so the
reason the videos I can't I can't really
articulate myself properly through
through words so I must rather do it you
know using my voice I'm bad with my
words so I thought I'd do it with words
is good I can see there's gonna be a
good one it's got that Christmas spirit
he came Christmas Day came at like 1:00
in the morning
Christmas Day I was asleep like you're
supposed to be under 1 a.m. as he's a
good boy no because if you if you stay
awake son that doesn't complain oh yeah
yeah he was on the nice list Santa's
here come down we left the mince pies
out but no one's eaten them JJ said he's
gonna smash your computer said he's
gonna smash my PC and all that and I was
confused to why he would do that you've
literally won him up absolutely
everything he's told you not to do
you've went and done and you're confused
to why he wants to smarten fees why
you're angry I started to record I was
going on in our conversation I'm not
gonna put it out there I don't want to I
don't know if it out there he's not
putting that out there but then he's
putting this out yeah
does this maybe make him look better
than what the other recording did I
I'll say it's a theory I've already put
it out there that he was recording he's
either one do what you think he wants to
keep it private
JJ's made many attempts to keep this
private you know news ignored every
single one so I think it at this point
to put that on him is not realistic
I think Deji is trying to win the hearts
of the people in doing videos like this
the point is that everyone's making
really rash decisions and then trying to
make videos justifying their rash
decisions and actually in healthy cycle
yeah what would be really great as if
dad you just removed himself from it but
I don't think judges being rush there's
anything he's never made a video about
that you you know I mean if he did say
he'd smashed his computer he said it's a
rash thing to say the reason is because
he's made my mom and my dad cry I mean
I've never seen my dad cry when you were
a little brother and your big brother
yes
hugely successful hmm and then you come
up and everyone tells you it's off of
the back of your big brother and there
is truth in that then you know there is
truth in that you know constantly in a
shuttle there's times where you're gonna
rebel against them even if you're in the
wrong you're just gonna be like nah [__]
it I want to be viewed as his equal
whenever JJ tells him not to do
something he's deliberately doing the
opposite because he's proving I'll do
whatever I want you don't own me you're
not gonna tell me what I do and I
understand it I understand the behavior
but at some point daddy needs to realize
he's doing damage to someone who has
helped him hugely in life judges the
type of person who's always gonna be
surrounded by people he's charismatic
he's a funny guy and he's got loads of
friends he's got the side men who've
always been his great people he's got
Randolph he's got the dolls there's all
these people are back on Deji as a
little brother might have watched JJ go
off and meet all these people and felt a
bit left behind
JJ studies controversies but he's never
been the type to have his dirty laundry
aired in this way this is not him it's
not the family comes from either one
thing I've learned about life is no
matter what happens nobody wants to see
themselves as the bad guy in their own
story like everyone generally seems to
find a way to pay themselves out in a
positive light no matter what scenario
huh
I feel like Deji needs to be a bit more
realistic with himself on the things
he's done and not just say logan paul
invited me on the podcast if Deji had
have just remained calm throughout all
of these scenarios in some way it would
never have ended up them fighting on
Christmas Day in LA never so the sidemen
come out and start turning on Deji I
have clearly been told to keep things
quiet from JJ it's not saying you know
you're out of order
it's Christmas Day you're kicking him
out sending Christmas on his own this
ain't right and then JJ says look you're
clearly tried to use this by making a
video on Christmas dear just in any way
you can't gain off of me as much as you
can stop [__] making videos about as
keemstar tweets out there he's lost nine
thousand subs 6 thousand subs easily
tweets out those numbers from Bob that's
adding to the collateral damage of this
publicly it's not going well so what
does daddy do
sup guys instead I'm gonna react to old
clips of me and JJ once again you tell
him not to do something and that's the
first thing he goes and does this is
just edgy rebelling against JJ you've
got anyway no it's not just nostalgic
it's just a good feeling it's not
nostalgic but when I look back I feel
good about it I have a healthy
relationship you need to have arguments
that's the thing there needs to be
fights and stuff you and I disagree on
things we don't go I'm gonna smash your
laptop by the looks of this drama money
involved in it maybe you could do a
little district on me I don't think that
would end well for you
no you would you know way too much yeah
yeah all those [__] over there not
for me hey guys I love my brother
just check the sub comb yeah yeah love
me brother yeah absolutely
I'll say I've had my conflicts they're
dropping they're dropping but we've also
gotten back together up and they coming
back up back up you know it is all of
this thought I just remember being in
the ring with them when they hugged
after their file is such enough and I
was like oh that's the moment that's
really huge that is that's a great
moment like I do believe Dougie loves
Georgiana he's just he needs to calm the
[__] down underneath my next favorite
feud at the moment on YouTube is GT
versa
all right yeah honestly Christmas Eve
they're still going at it getting each
other yeah on each other it was it's
amazing start for me got these guys in
samanage [__] think about it man can
I just say some of these guys are
terrible managers they go I've been
working on this all week and you guys
are [__] then there's a spate there
they thought they were gonna win good
luck because you don't always public
they didn't this all seems really
scripted like not as important as what
yeah yeah like we didn't take the
Wembley Cup as important as this oh no
but then we are not DT probably decided
to keep here in a second chance so yeah
we're lucky involved then with three
games let me finish a sentence what a
cause I've never seen must been a really
cloudy day a series where we take
ourselves way too seriously seriously so
seven days until aft vfc you come face
to face with their biggest YouTube
rivals in the most anticipated game all
time they came the whole world has been
waiting for to do know that what
happened
finally the stars of a line the start of
a life literally you call each other up
and go fancy a game this Sunday stars it
alone we're going Nando's really is it
open yeah the stars in the cities the
cities lying wait [__] Moscow well
they're not meeting for the next [__]
name the Magomedov fight no no they're
waiting no for AF T V versus United
stunned and the main man behind the
united stand mark golfing there is if
all the bloody resistance ever poppadom
patching up all involved you know I like
about Gore bridge choose the morning 9
o'clock in the morning I'll just be
getting the coffee or whatever
football's not on my mind every minute
of a night he will be morning about Man
United all [__] day every day he's
relentless
so that's DT DT and Gor bridge no wait
no good that was a TT TT doesn't take
your line no you take that well
[Music]
I'm talking now all right
although to be fair the referees done
the right thing there this guy's given
the camera look don't know why been
school buoyed by the rat he'll love it
oh that was a literal swing well done
boy seek well then you both are sent off
time to leave now that united stand one
yeah just how office is this just as
duties wasn't was copies really one this
bearing in mind right it doesn't end
there
what on Christmas Eve that being each
other winners don't look back so as far
as a rematch more chance of [__]
gold bricks for a year already beaten
you once and that was enough take the L
embrace the L love your L and keep
taking else right so that obviously is
pretty annoyed not gold [__] bricks
JT responds at half eight on Christmas
Eve it's no secret that me and Mark hate
each other in the youtube world boxing
seems to be the word difference are
sorted that's boring so I've offered him
another alternative day T versus gold
bridge in a cage one-on-one like FIFA
Street nor F no rules winner-take-all
streamline if there's no rules how do
you know who's won yeah good good point
that's a really good point if these who
did get in a boxing ring I thought I
would have to watch it it would be it
would be dynamite it would be it would
be amazing it's cuz it's real they're
really doing like each other unreal
reason I don't care though 99% to
YouTube it's all fake it's all hugs
afterwards they're tweeting each other
on Christmas Eve you're supposed to be
having time with your family but know
these two are still a just that
appreciate this [__] that's where
you and I differ yes moving on is so
crazy
I met you a month ago at Whole Foods
mm-hmm now we're living together that's
how this works
he's a man who's not quite as in love as
she is I met you a month ago in Whole
Foods and now we're in love and his
reply is not brilliant he goes that's
how this works in your head you're like
what kind of nonchalant [__] can I say
to you that non-committal but also
reaffirms what you think is going on yes
how that wolf food always love that
place
always loved Whole Foods for the time I
was like a kid it always gave me such a
warm feeling inside
Whole Foods gave you a warm feeling
inside you know what gives me a warm
feeling Lawrence hasta oh my god they
lift that that's how they're painting
they keep up the doodling yeah that does
look like a fun lifestyle isn't it this
is what your life should be like nice
it's very Lawrence Mackay it's so nice
it's safe the show I hate like a lovely
person but I hate people this is really
weirdly similar arsenalfan TV people who
think they're just like the center of
their own worlds what I'd love right now
is a double-decker bus to just come of
course we've only got each other no
we're gonna have to use one arm each
yeah I mean that's definitely
insensitive she probably sharks like a
minx gentleman she's not free love she's
bound to be wild in bed but then you've
got to keep up with all the pretentious
bollocks I like you wouldn't do that in
order to have sex with this woman oh I'm
sayin that's why I'm the thysen with him
right thank you no Majan you going there
I can imagine her home you taught me to
shine and you going why i lo I taught
you so for enjoying your [__] shag as
well totally a shine in this Bell end up
with your mouth but in all surviving a
video although I'd love to edit a
version most she's saying that things
and then your reply with that as well
thank you for talking I love when you
talk
your voice and that guy no talking is
unnecessary but also words are my love
language words all my love long heavy
you it made it the official words are
just language my love language come on
he's talking just as much bollocks as
Deji but when he says it it's not
alright imagine if Deji sat in front of
a video and when I'm tall I'm not
talking with my words I'm talking with
my love language like I think in
feelings didn't see this world through
words
that's why I need to have you talk to me
I don't know
that right now I feel like she's on
another level to him intellectually
speaking and he's just doing his best to
keep according smoothie balls what do
you think the state Israel and Palestine
and he goes mmm Oh full mouth of
smoothie bowl for mayor I can't reply
now love that is like bad glad good what
makes you feel bad about it it's
probably broken liked in this suffer all
the suffering all the suffering and we
don't like suffering and he's like no we
don't know another smoothie Bowl I tell
you sell me that painting
if I was still gonna everything good we
are good at every I never believed that
I couldn't do something might be the
best artists on this planet [__]
nerd to the end agree on it he also
turned into a valley girl midway through
so but earlier he goes yeah [__] cool
man whatever and then she goes I just
love and you guys you might be the best
[__] artist on this planet I love the
fact that he is blatantly talking
absolute bollocks I love it he will say
anything to just keep them [__] [__]
walls coming are that is horrible Brian
honestly right if they're together in a
year I'll be [__] shot you can't take
off on a relationship like that why not
without it exploding like a star a
long-term lasting one yeah an aeroplane
right just took off gently and they're
not a hairy edge on there no what about
Harrier jumped yet Harriers can take off
like that I thought the harrier jump jet
could communally or if that hurricane
but I'm talking about Boeing 747 so
Kevin Spacey's been accused of a few
things
understood the only segment of this
engine Kevin Spacey's been accused of
doing some things with some men and we
won't go any further into it because at
the moment we don't know
what's true and what isn't you noticed
the YouTube video on themselves
50k subs did he set this channel of
purely to don't know but let's watch it
and see I know what you want oh sure
they may have tried to separate us but
what we have is too strong is too
powerful I mean after all we shared
everything you know do you know do mines
me of when you go and visit like a dead
relative you've got a bit of a look to
them where the colors drained from their
faces yeah yeah I shocked you with my
honesty but mostly I challenged you and
made you think and you trusted me is he
trying to justify touching people by
saying that we knew we shouldn't trust
him I wonder you can we can agree on the
[__] cannot I've watched him in
other [__] and he's always fantastic and
what he do that you've got to give them
sexual predator credit no we don't know
fears or that's what you've just said we
don't know that right although an
abnormal amount of people are coming out
abnormal amount of people and I'm
hearing an abnormal amount of stories
behind the scenes from an abnormal
amount of men I can't say who but you
wouldn't believe the worst without
evidence would you you wouldn't rush to
judgments without facts would you it's
very hard to get evidence and facts when
your semen has already drained from
their bottles I don't know if that is a
fact by the way that is one of the
general genuine problems when you do
these things that he's been accused of
doing yeah it's a sexual act that
happens on a night and a year later when
you come to say well this happened to me
the evidence isn't there I don't know if
he has been accused of having anal sex
how much so I'm just saying generally
though anyhow
despite all the popping cogs a copy
would we both know where you want to
copy Yoker copy was the nickname of one
of his old boyfriends if you are
genuinely not guilty of things you take
it seriously yeah and therefore do a
sincere and public in denial of it
you're also not going to vengo let me
make some statements where you don't
know which way I'm going so ambiguous
I've at the end I'm like where's this
good this is not a TV show me this is
your life we both know I've done
terrible things but then of a the
terrible things that you think I
terribly did say I'm not actually
you think I'm something forwards like
what you're a murderer so it turns out
he didn't touch everyone he's just a
[__] murderer I think all that that
video confirm for me to cut a long story
short was he definitely stole some [__]
Chris Brown claims he does not own an
exotic monkey as he faces criminal
charges and up to six months in prison
for possessing never restricted primates
imagine imagine after everything he's
been through he gets done for holding a
monkey all this bad [__] and then people
go [__] got him what for monkey monkey
I thought we should look back a little
bit in 2018 this was a big trend this
year look at him what the [__] just
happened could you maybe drag a child by
the angles that quick zoom I mean that
looks likely scramblers [__] brains
ya know 20 people out there that are
commenting on our YouTube channel
or Instagram or Twitter Jay you fouled
the Christmas calendar you guys a
[__] [__] guess wha
suck your fat [__] mom yet if you
complain in our comment section about
the Christmas calendar failing and all
you're gonna do is complain on YouTube
in our comment section then a happy [__]
you
unsubscribe you ain't welcome and yeah
boy I think he's right because what
annoys me is it's like the Christmas Day
podcast that we put up right two and a
half hours where to get everyone in one
place at one time and 50 grand
well not but we had two camera operators
six cameras everyone traveled yeah we
all put ourselves out to make sure that
we got this video done specifically so
that people would have something nice on
Christmas Day and not have to watch the
bore and [__] that your grandparents
wanna watch and there was still comments
about sound issues and everything in the
comments and you're like in the grand
scheme of things is it that important to
mourn about it when you're getting a
free video do you ever think people
complain because they think they're
helping there's ways of doing it or
there's ways of wording things and a lot
of these YouTube comments are worded
kunti I wish for those people thought
there was a button to stop them from
being able to watch your videos
[__] your view I don't want you to come
back I don't want you say anything you
are removing the right for you to watch
my [__] that's what I want I'd love to
have that kind of control I want you to
read this out exactly one year ago
sugar daddy Brad isn't like a Brad
passed away he was 47 and died because
of a heart attack and untreated diabetes
we had an incredibly toxic relationship
and ultimately I wish I never met him as
horrible as he was I'm sitting here and
trying to dig up a good memory to
remember him on this day so here it is
Brad you bought me my first pair of
Louboutins and my first and only
racehorse you understood the value of my
time and for that I honor you my time
today Oh God
by making this post for you I still
don't forgive you for taking me out of
the will after you attacked me while you
were on whippets however you knew I
would always be okay
and yes I've been living a double life
this whole time with the guy you thought
was my gay bodyguard and I'm also an
author and serial entrepreneur you've
got all of the girls moxie sure you got
it now come Kirkham drew my eye towards
this a post about a Zimbabwean pastor
who was arrested for selling tickets to
heaven I'll tell you what killed the
fighting that beloved the sushis they
hear about this they'll be on that wagon
straightaway this is a real picture of
the tickets to heaven Tito Watts
a Zimbabwean clergyman and his wife
Amanda were arrested for selling tickets
to heaven I do not care what people or
the police are saying about me I'm being
persecuted because I'm doing the work of
God and it cut up two by fours i
spray-painted gold and it was Jesus who
give them to me behind the KFC and said
to sell them so I could get me some
money to go to outer space I met an
alien named Stevie who said if I got the
cash together he'd take me and my wife
on his flying saucer to the planet
that's made entirely of crack cocaine
now at this point I thought this must be
an onion article no this is actual
footage of said priest doing priestly
things lower this man's act is to call
heaven on a mobile phone and pretend
he's speaking to Evan is this Irvin
[Applause]
I hate bullshitters like this if this is
how far he's taken his scamming imagine
how much II I mean the [__]
rocking a Rolex in a custom-made suit
look imagine what else he's got all this
people who cheat poor people out of
money they're just you know a name of
God [__] James Charles the one who
damned I'm Alex on his penis size all he
wants for Christmas is a good dick to
suck on and we and we all know Oh James
alex is an option I guess if you do want
a good dick suck for Christmas I don't
know if how likes his dick is good
that's the only thing I would love to
see you and James Charles collaborate in
2019 why not do you know I mean I've
gone all the way before Jimmy where you
think oh all the way in that way not in
that way I've collaborated by heavily
with people you wouldn't have expected
me to that's so true this one is called
the food reviewer reviews alcohol food a
new reviews on the youtubes you never
knew such a cool dude I keep it so food
all right
right love you at leaked footage the
food reviewer reviews and hobbies try to
suppress it but yeah is so wasted
such a good love imagine being the
parents watching this I love because
y'all will be [__] we watched him grow
up in pulverize now he's like a he's
like a what is it a bird just fly I just
tried to imagine him flying and it just
didn't work in my head for a minute
it's there Mary happy new year yeah
thanks for everyone who supported us in
2008 even that was true news for this
week we'll be doing another one next
week it's been a wonderful year it's the
most wonderful year of the of them so
anyway hopefully you've enjoyed true
news more that coming 2080 podcasts all
the good stuff second channel everything
check it all the links in description
below thanks EU laws great yeah
everything's being great subscribe see
ya